wedding news for singer ciara and  quarterback Russell Wilson photos  surfaced online on Tuesday fueling  speculation that the couple got married  in Liverpool England well we can tell  you that Sierra's rep tells us they are  not married yet but we've learned they  are expected to tie the knot this week  she said yes yeah I can this thing  happen on baby Wilson proposed with a  massive diamond ring instagramming this  video after they got engaged in March  I'm so excited God is so good all the  time the big day is coming just days  after Sierra's appearance at the essence  festival in new orleans on sunday john  king heavenly because look at the bottom  line a source close to the singer tells  ET she wanted to get married when no one  expected it  you